hey guys what's up this is andrew for
travelingsensors.com
so yesterday we had another view of the
equity market
with um the nikkei the eurostars and the
s p
today i want to go to the forex market
because the forex market
is the most liquid market in the world
so of course it has a lot of information
for me it's kind of a leading
indicator of what is going to happen on
the equity market
the reason behind that is i think that
you know technical analysis is just
about analyzing
where the market is going by analyzing
the flows uh
and the flows the real flows are in the
forex market
the most shredded pair i think is the
euro dollar and maybe the second one
must be the dollar yen so we're gonna
have
a quick view on those two today
and make some technical analysis so once
again technical analysis
is to try to find some support levels
resistance levels by using different
tools
i like to use trend lines very efficient
for me i like to use fibonacci
iliad waves principle and the macd and
moving averages as well
so let's get into it
all right so this is the euro dollar
pair
we're gonna first on those kind of
instruments
i like to first have a very
long term um view analysis
and then i'm going to zoom in slowly and
slowly kind of a top-down approach
to try to understand where this market
could potentially be heading
so here we had a first move up until the
208 crisis
and then a strong move down all right
the the smooth down was actually uh
happening
because uh the dollar was getting
stronger
all right so now wha so what do we see
we see here
a very obvious uh downward sloping trend
line
that has one two three reactions
and look what is happening here we are
trying to break it
but it has not been working on the
monthly to be broken you need to find a
candle that closes above it
so like this one and the second one as
well this is the confirmation
you know so of course you can start to
trade at the first one
but it's more secure to wait for the
confirmation here the confirmation has
closed here so if you buy here and you
sell here it's not a good trade
then we do a trend line from here i
connect the two lows that i have here
and here
so this is uh like kind of my strongest
support which is quite far it's a 107
but it's still to me worth mentioning
then you can have uh not then that's it
for now
then so i go to the weekly so on the
weekly charts uh what do we see we see
the same thing is that uh here we have a
lot of consolidation taking place
so once again this is to me not a
coincidence you know
this is uh not a surprise that this
consolidation is happening at this level
it's because there is the trend line
coming here and you have a real battle
between the bulls and the bears so what
is behind this battle
let me tell you what i see behind this
battle
it's basically a battle for who is going
to print
the most between the u.s and europe
because when you print money uh
you're not drinking actually you're
printing currency not
money you know the the money is the
value is the same
but you have more currency which makes
your currency
weaker it's called inflation all right
uh the currency is weaker for the same
amount of currency you can buy less it's
like you have the feeling that the price
is going higher
but no the price is the same you just
have more currency for the same
kind of value and who can print
more between the us and europe who can
print more
of course the united states why because
they have a stronger growth
so the market is more willing to lend
money to those who have a strong
growth um just because there are
very good candidates to one day um
give back this money look if you for
example this
this would work for example for you and
me if i go to the bank and i want to
borrow a big amount of money
they're going to look at my salary
they're going to say right this guy
looks
like he's doing well so we can lend him
money
and looks like it's growing you know so
it's
very um reassuring for investors to lend
money
to someone that has growth if your
salary is actually going lower
it means you have some issues and people
would be scared to lend you so they they
could but at a higher rate
so to me this is what is taking place
here
the united states can get
indebted far more than the other
countries because
it's the united states and have growth
and they are the best in the world
that's kind of true i mean economically
today i think it's still true they are
the best they're just you know the
the system is just working amazingly and
they're just
killing it every day the battle here is
are we gonna have
more u.s printing or not of course yes
but would it be more than europe or not
and i think the answer is yes
basically if the market is bullish this
would go higher
or the other way around if this goes
higher
it means that the market would be
bullish i see it this way
so to me here it's very interesting to
notice what's going to happen in the
coming months
and i don't know um here on my trend
line
we have not broken broken it clearly
and we don't know if the market is gonna
get lower or higher
we need something more clear to do this
we have one more tool we haven't used
yet here
which is idiot wave principle uh idiot
waves here can be very
helpful because let me go to the daily
it can help you to
feel if this move up is finished so very
quickly
iliot wave uh principle basically is
telling you
that moves in the direction of the
market so here bullish
are developing in five waves and moves
uh that are corrective are developing in
three wave
usually abc patterns basically you can
have different kind of
patterns you can have zigzag for the abc
flat
or triangle and for the moves up you can
have impulse or diagonal
but i'm gonna for those who are
interested to know more i'm gonna
make a free video for this you just need
to subscribe to my newsletter in the
link below
and don't forget by the way to like the
the video if you if you enjoy this and
subscribe to the channel
and those who are going to subscribe to
my newsletter are going to receive a
free video where i explain
everything about elliot and very quickly
because this guy is just a genius
so ralph ellison illiot uh he was a
trader in the
30s 40s and he just
saw that there were patterns in the in
the market and
he spent his whole life analyzing it so
he was basically he had some like
um issues with his health so basically
he was just staying home all
the time and he was analyzing the data
and
it was just crazy he he was the best the
best trader at this time he won a
competition
with real money trading where he made i
think something like 400 percent
in in a matter of month he was first by
far
and then he of course explained how he
did it he didn't want to keep
it for himself he wanted to spread
everything he discovered and
this is actually in his book that i read
that is just
amazing and that i'm trying to um
sum up as best as i can and i'm using
this for like a couple of years
and to me it's very helpful let me show
you how
here very quickly so
we are analyzing this move is it
finished or not because if not
then i know i'm gonna break the trend
line if yes then we're gonna probably
come back here
so elliot is gonna give us some
information so i
do five waves i try one two
very obvious then the third wave is it
here then we have four and five
maybe and then this would be finished
but look why discounting is not
very nice for me the third wave is
always the strongest
usually impulsive and usually extended
extended means there are five waves
into the third wave here the third wave
is weak
you know and i have only like one two
three wave in it
so it doesn't look like a third wave
because it's like almost the same length
as the first one
it's it's not the shortest so it's a
valid count it could be like this
but to me this is not the the best
counting you can make here the best
counting would be
one two three
four and five why
because this is a beautiful third wave
because in my third wave
i have one two three four
five as well
okay so in the third wave uh i have
a beautiful like fi i have five
beautiful
waves so i think this is a valid count
and one more thing
usually when you have the second wave
that is a zigzag so zigzag is
b c very basic then the false wave is a
flat
correction or a triangle and here look
what we have looks like this is a
descending triangle
what is a triangle a triangle is just
when you have a horizontal
base like this and you have a
downtrend for example or uptrend like
coming from the bottom
and then into the ascending triangle but
this is a descending triangle
and descending triangles usually take
time to develop you know that's what is
said
in the book and it's true that's what i
see too and i think that this
looks to me very much like a descending
triangle
who usually which usually develop into
five or seven waves so one
two three four five six seven
this to me is what is playing out and
how i know it
how i think i know it of course i'm not
sure it's thanks to elliot
so and my trend lines because it's like
a combination of those two
information uh so what kind of trend can
you make here
you can just sell here stop loss at this
level
for example so you take your position
here so you can make two percent
and you can lose um so you you sell here
so at 1 18 8 for example and you stop
loss at
122 you know so you can lose uh
40 beeps 40 beeps to make 2.2
one to five rescue world trade we go for
it this is a nice trade
and then what do you do when you arrive
here you do the opposite
so you can have two percent to take
again uh for like 20 or 30 beeps
loss because this trend line is quite
clear one two
reactions very precise so this is
telling me if the market trades below
we have a problem and once again the
real dollar pair
is the most liquid player in the world
there there is something like 5 000
billion dollars trading every day on the
forex market and a big part of it is
trending in the euro dollar
why i'm saying this because when we have
liquidity then technical analysis is
more efficient because we have the algo
that's actually helping us because all
this algo they see
all of this you know it's been a long
time to see it but
today they just don't miss any obvious
trend line they don't miss any
obvious fibonacci uh retracement they
are just
helping us to to make our trades
more likely to be uh clean and this
is this i think would be very clean here
we probably gonna have
a nice reaction at the 1
1605 level all right let's call it 116.
what's in still 116 level is going to be
a very strong support so you sell at 119
118 8 even a slightly below 118.7
and you buy at 116 and you do this for a
couple of months you can
uh generate some nice profits but
here if we come here then it tells me
that it was actually
really looking like a triangle all right
because it was long in time you know
weak in correction in spots but
strong in time correction you know it
takes time so this
looks like a triangle which usually
takes time
to develop so if we arrive here
and i have two uh so here i do a trend
line connecting
the bottom of the first wave and the
bottom of the
of the third wave and if we arrive here
then i would probably uh take a massive
long position
with stop loss a bit below because we
have two different supports
and i have also idiot with me so i have
everything
and if you have to it's enough to take a
tread and especially i would believe
more in my scenario that this market was
just
will just blow up blow up on the upside
and
how far it would go usually when you
have a third wave that is extended which
is the case here
extended because in my third wave i have
one two three four five
then usually um the fifth wave is the
same
length than the first wave uh usually
uh so this would give us something like
four eight percent
okay so 121.5 all right so this is my
target so i buy here
and i sell here and then i would
actually if this
uh plays out i would actually wait for a
re-test
somewhere here or i would use fibonacci
of this whole move up
and i would buy massively again here
and this i would keep for years because
once again if we go back to the
monthly what is playing out
if this trend line which is in
on the verge to be broken is actually
broken with this fifth wave and we go to
the 120 area and we stay here for a
couple of weeks
month then i'm bullish for the coming
years
and what kind of
level i have in mind let me tell you
this i use
fib again i connect the lowest point
of the of this market with its highest
points and look
what happens magic
you can you had this level given by
fibonacci already
since 2008 you know and this level
happened in 2015 so seven years later
fibonacci already had this level here
but of course you're gonna tell me it
had here
it had this one as well and it didn't
play out but look it played out here
so then uh and then the 50 of course
played out here
and now where are we guys where are we
we are on the
61.8 percent uh ratio
uh feeb retracement the garden number
again that we can find everywhere
because i'll go see
it as well and we are here the
consolidation is actually
on the trend line and on the fib
retracement this is the strongest feed
retracement the 38.261.8
with the 50 but this is not a golden
ratio
are the strongest retracement where you
find the more liquidity
and look what is happening we had the
mega d cross over
as well on the monthly so the macd is
with us
elliot with is with us is with us um
trend lines are gonna be with us if
those two plays out
so 116 massive long position this is
my view and where we go we go to the
next field retracement
as we always do so we're gonna first go
to the 125
and then probably go to the 133 so those
are my levels
for 22 to 23 you know for the
this coming years i think the euro is
going to 130
135 we're coming we're coming back there
why
because the fed is going to print very
big amount of money
more than europe because they have
growth and they can do it i think that
the us are now in debt
of 25 000 billion dollars and only
uh 7 000 billion dollars on the fed
balance sheet but trust me they can go
much higher they can go to 10 billion
000 by the end of year they won't do it
they would keep for next year and for
the coming years because the
economic outlook is bad guys and we need
to print money
we need to print money and this the
story is going together
with uh the markets going well if this
happens
it means the markets are going well at
least the u.s market
but let's see let's be very careful this
can of course
uh be completely wrong
if we break the 116 level so if we break
the 116 level
then probably the equity market is going
down as well
and it means that we need to reconsider
everything
um and probably get short here probably
stop our long position on the equity
market
if we have some but we have the stop
loss on those markets as well
and take some nice short positions
because it means we're bearish we're
gonna probably revisit
the low points we had in march if this
happens i don't believe it for now i
don't believe it but
illiot waves once again i come back to
it because
what this guy uh who is i think the most
amazing trader in the history in the
recent history
this guy actually predicted so he's dead
now unfortunately
uh but he has predicted that we're gonna
have the strongest bull market that ever
happened
uh and that it's gonna be unpredictable
and
bigger than everyone thinks look what is
happening since 2008 in 2015 everybody
was saying all right we are bearish
in 2020 everybody said we are bearish
and
where are we we are bullish where are we
going
higher who said that 30 years ago
elliot and what else he said he said
that then we're gonna have the biggest
crisis that never happened in the
history as well
but before that we need to finish this
bull market and i'm gonna make some
other videos where i make a longer term
analysis on the equity
and it's very interesting to see where
we are
in the very long run you know and we are
very extended but we still have some
room on the upside
so yes very quickly so i'm done for the
euro dollar
i hope this was interesting guys once
again if you like please
uh hit the like button and subscribe to
the channel it really helps me
and it's gonna make me do more video
like this one
the euro the dollar yen pair so what do
we have
same i'm on the daily time frame
and what i can see here is that we have
this big
resistance here
let's go to the weekly monthly no
okay so if i go to the weekly time frame
so i have this uh downward sloping trend
line that i connected
this slow this high with this high and
we have three
four reactions so this trendline is
strong
on the downside what do we have where
our supports our supports are here in
2014
you can see multiple reactions and here
kovi 19 put the dollar yen at this level
as well
so first support second support here
now what is the trend guys what is the
trend
here you can just look at the macd the
macd is giving you the trend if you guys
don't see it
uh the macd is at minus
all 86 very negative
the weekly macd is very negative because
we are very strong
bearish trend now i go to the daily
on the daily it's at it's negative as
well and actually we just had
so on the daily we have this trend line
on the shorter time frame
that is basically protecting us if we
are short here
if we trade above this it's time to cut
the position
and for now where are our next targets
so we are bearish and our next targets
are at 101.99
so i think the market is heading there
um so if
it comes back here you can have a nice
short position here with a tight stop
loss of course
and if it comes back here then you can
have a long position
so for now we're just like between if
you are short keep your position because
this is going lower you know this is
going lower
uh we have the macd crossover uh and we
have a negative macd so bearish momentum
uh downward sloping trendline it's
protecting us very easy to trade this
kind of
moves because if you sell here and your
stop-loss is the trend line
if you go lower and you don't buy and it
comes back here then your stop-loss is
already below the level you sold
all right so you oh you are already
profitable and
you stop your position this is called a
trailing stop loss
it's very nice to use those and it's
perfect when you have a nice uh trend
line a nice sloping trend line
all right that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video
uh i'm gonna try to talk about some
maybe
u.s stocks next time like tesla apple
everything
uh if you have anything that you think
is interesting
is interesting for me to talk about that
you want to see don't hesitate to
comment below
i'm gonna have a look at it and i'm
gonna try to come up with
some more uh technical analysis
that might uh help you guys to do
your trades so once again those markets
are very volatile
if you're having some position be very
careful
trade with a tight stop loss and stay
close to shore
i see you guys